foreign
this story could not be real you if you
were making a fee someone would say okay
that's too no no it's not possible it's
not it's not real it's not possible make
it real I have no inconvenience in
saying and explaining what really
happened and if I have to go to jail
because I have said something which I
should not say
someone tell me
[Music]
and I went back home
and I say to my wife This Is the End
wake up to my sons and say
today is the end
[Music]
the start of case against me and against
my wife
I think this is a process to make fear
but lost everything I start from zero
sooner the later they will try to indict
us for whatever money laundering
child abuse
drug trafficking or whatever they will
invent it and they will try it because
at the end it's not a matter of result
it's a matter of destroying the person
and with in that way destroying the line
of defense
[Applause]
I agree with
interval of law
and I also agree with
basic terms of democracy
but they don't
so it's quite strange no to protecting
the name of democracy the heritage of
the dictatorship
no separation of powers no respect
you never believe that you will be the
target of a conspiracy or that you will
be in the middle of a story like this
one I mean this is something that you
see in the news
people is getting for that and we'll get
to a point that will explode and Dora
will pay the price unfortunately we'll
pay the price the young people
especially that my father wasn't that
that he had a problem because the
government sold other country to America
[Music]
Our Story begins in Andorra a micro
country with a land mass of 181 square
miles consisting of a couple of valleys
in the Pyrenees Mountains landlocked
between France and Spain with a total
population of less than 80 000 people
you can seat the entire population of
andorra's capital city inside Madison
Square Garden if you've never heard of
the country of Andorra until now you are
not alone it's not uncommon for an
enduring resident entering the United
States to be stopped by passport control
and question under the accusation of
carrying a fake passport from a fake
country
the quality of life in Andorra is one of
the highest in the world no poverty no
crime and ranked in the top five safest
countries the source of its healthy GDP
comes from 8 million tourists visiting
annually for its skiing duty-free
shopping and its banking system
Andorra first gained its independence in
the year 1278 and for the next 700 years
Andorra was ruled by medieval feudal
overlords until it finally created an
executive legislative and judicial
branch of government when it first
established its constitution in 1993.
[Music]
persona
[Music]
media
[Music]
while Andor is the world's only
co-principality it's 1993 Constitution
also added democratically elected
presidents
foreign
[Music]
Hoyas Dinero
Yas Este Dinero
is
muchas fortunas de Andorra unlike other
countries that utilized Offshore Banking
as a Haven to hide their stolen wealth
during World War II and Dora's Flagship
Bank Was Born This Way
Offshore Banking simply refers to the
deposit of funds by a company or
individual in a bank that is located
outside of their National residence it's
not always a vacation destination like
the Cayman Islands Bermuda or the
British Virgin Islands Offshore Banking
is everywhere with some of the most
accessible Offshore Banking located
right inside the United States this
simple fact of opening a bank account
offshore
doesn't imply that you are doing
something wrong
let's take Argentina
Argentina is a country where
approximately every 10 years some way or
another one way or another the
government steals the money from its
population either by means of inflation
either by means of seizing the money
they fund they find their way they are
very creative for that so if you're
Argentina what you do is just to first
to have dollars not pesos and second
just to hide your wealth under your
mattress if you can or if you can afford
it just to go somewhere else in the
world and store your money there however
most of the world's Fortune 500
companies store trillions of dollars of
their profits offshore to avoid paying
taxes
293 Fortune 500 companies with offshore
earnings collectively owe 752 billion
dollars in federal taxes that's 52
billion dollars more than the bank
bailout of 2008. celebrities businessmen
world leaders and politicians from both
sides of the aisles safely store their
wealth in Offshore Banking to avoid
paying taxes by opening up fake shell
companies to hide their money America's
IRS is powerless over this so they audit
the poor instead given the inherent
secrecy and anonymity of shell companies
terrorist funding drug and human
trafficking profits and all sorts of
criminal money laundering is rampant
every day openly open the newspaper and
you will see all these news about
criminal networks all that money most of
it is passing through the financial
system and the most a bank can do is
just apply certain controls which are
standardized so in that regard the banks
the most they can do is just to try to
minimize
the damage the problem is that the trend
and not in many countries in the last 10
years from the authorities the police
has been to point to the to the banks
and to the individuals working at those
Banks and they are making them
responsible of what their clients do you
can't fight you can make your best you
can have a very big team a very but you
cannot avoid money laundering it's not
possible it's like the poly poly you
have to avoid criminals and they say
okay we have a policia we have the
police we don't have criminals no you
have the police and you have criminals
you have compliance department and you
have monuments if a client comes to make
a deposit at your bank with a briefcase
with one million dollars staying with
blood well maybe
there are some leading indicators here
that they pointed something is wrong but
honestly it's completely uncontrolled
in the wake of the Attacks of September
the 11th America introduced the Patriot
Act and within it also introduced
something called a section 311 to
promote the prevention detection and
prosecution of international money
laundering and financing of terrorism
section 311 of the USA Patriot Act
grants the director of fincen The
Authority upon finding that reasonable
grounds exist for concluding that a
foreign jurisdiction foreign financial
institution class of transactions or
type of accounts is of primary money
laundering concern to require domestic
financial institutions and financial
agencies to take certain special
measures to address the primary money
laundering concern fincen May impose one
or more of these special measures in
order to protect the U.S financial
system from these threats fincen stands
for the U.S Department of treasuries
Financial crimes enforcement Network a
section 311 notice issued by Vincent
consists of nothing more than a standard
press release section 311 was designed
to deal with a very severe problem that
could lead to a need for emergency
action and it's being used for anything
but it's a tool and it's being used you
know for other political or regulatory
goals and there's really no there's no
recourse while the September 11th
attacks cost the terrorists a half a
million dollars to execute in 2012 HSBC
and offshore Bank originating in Hong
Kong was caught and openly admitted to
assisting the Sinaloa drug cartel and
terrorist organization in Mexico to
launder at least 881 million dollars
enough to pay for
1762 September 11th attacks fincen never
issued a section 311 against HSBC and
HSBC is still operating business as
usual in 2017 when Denmark's offshore
Bank danska bank was caught and admitted
to laundering 230 billion dollars of
criminal money for the Russian State the
equivalent of 460
000 September 11th attacks fincen never
issued a section 311 against donska Bank
either in fact no large Commercial Bank
of primary money laundering concern has
ever had a section 311 issued against
them some of the banks are really making
a business line out of doing really bad
business or their procedures and
policies you could drive a truck through
nobody goes to jail and these banks are
so large that they're not going to get
shut down
and so what you have is a a situation
where only the little guys in the little
places where it's not going to cause a
disruptive effect system-wide and so in
that sense the biggest wrongdoers have
the most insulation and the the smallest
wrongdoors are those that aren't even
doing wrong at all are going to be
victims without any meaningful redress
and if you look at who
has been gone after with Section 311
notices they are almost always smaller
banks in smaller places to begin
I am Juan tejulo I did my studies in
Barcelona about the economics I stayed
for quite 30 years in Lakisha which now
is kasha bank and finally I came to
Andorra to bangka Privada BPA which was
a bank who was trying to
grow up because I was advertised when I
came to Andorra that
country was near to lose its condition
of tax Heaven more sooner than later
because of the pressure of Spain and
France against attacks heavens and in
fact immediately we bought a bank in
Spain which was Bank of Madrid and we
had clear from the first moment that our
future was in the onshore system not in
the offshore one it has its days
near to close and then Bank of Madrid
was the general of the ground and it was
a history of success until the moment
that the bank came on March 10 2015 the
United States treasury's fincen issued a
section 311 press release against BPA
I didn't know who were Vincent until
that moment
and the the three or four persons that
were in the room
we didn't know anything about fencing I
have no idea what Vincent was to be
honest I knew what was he said but they
don't for me that was a normal day
the bank went to my to the office at 12
o'clock the enough call me
and say something you had to come to
enough
to our offices and then Santi appears he
said we need to go to the enough
you know
regulatory you deal with the relator I
said we need to go do enough
and myself
and we stay there waiting waiting
waiting and they didn't explain anything
and we started just to talk up obviously
Among Us saying what's going on and they
said we have no idea of what's going on
nobody tell us they say that we cannot
go out they didn't allow us to live
which was quite surprising that in a San
Diego he said I need to grow his
diabetic so he said I need to go out my
father is a diabetic person so he needs
his insulin and my mom told me I just
went to the to the place where all the
people of the bank were she came
actually we I remember I said to him do
you have a phone charger that spare at
home yes please bring because we were
running out of batteries with all the
messages because I received other
messages from other people saying the
world in the street is that the BPA is
bankrupt other people was telling me the
bank has liquidity problems I mean I
said that that's impossible so I mean I
discarded those and then we start to
look at internet
the notice is issued we saw that notice
in our cell phones
it surprised us for me it was incredible
it's like a shock because they are
talking about some things that are not
real
to be honest the first reaction that we
had was of of we relaxed because we saw
what was on the North this makes no
sense the notice is this full full of
misrepresentations I would say of the of
the actual facts and also the the notice
has outdated uh information and we were
relaxed I mean like okay we we can we
can handle this it's not that we have
you know an account from Osama Bin Laden
and we didn't know about that that will
be a huge problem so they issued a
section 311 notice it was under the
patreon ACT there was no suggestion of
any terrorism whatever andora's
president Antonio Marty immediately
appeared on television
the capitals
qualifications
they were not simply just an interim
tank they were Spanish Banks so they had
to subject all of their policies and
procedures to the scrutiny of a European
Union regulator which had to meet all
European Union regulations and they
hired top accounting firms to do the
work and make sure they were running it
properly and fully in accordance with
the andoran regulatory system but also
with global standards on money
laundering 99 of the world's top 1 000
companies are regularly audited by at
least one of the world's top four major
accounting firms KPMG Del point
pricewaterhousecoopers and Ernst and
Young based on the international
anti-money laundering regulations
established by the United Nations
article 52 prevention and detection of
transfers of proceeds of crime KPMG
conducted independent annual anti-money
laundering audits of BPA from 2008 to
2012 overlapping with Deloitte
independently auditing BPA in 2007 and
2013 followed by a 2014 audit completed
by andorra's own Financial intelligence
unit all three of these independent
audits demonstrated zero money
laundering activity during the same time
frame that America's section 311 alleges
BPA was engaging in money laundering
March 11 2015 24 hours after America's
section 311 against a BPA Maria kosan
the director of anaph and Dora's
Financial regulator goes on National
Television assuring the people of
Andorra that's everything is fine
Sovereign
people bpa's small sister branch in
Panama is ordered liquidated BPA
Panama's liquidation and audit was
headed by Jamie D Gamboa in my direct
communication with Mr de Gamboa he
confirmed his role and confirmed an
independent two-year audit concluding
that no money laundering transactions
were detected the following morning on
March 12th 48 hours after America's
section 311 the andoran government and a
nav headed by Maria kosan suddenly
contradict everything they had said in
the previous 48 hours and ordered all
BPA customer accounts Frozen allowing
each customer a maximum withdrawal of
2500 Euros per week causing Mass
protests in Andorra with bpa's customers
demanding full access to their accounts
the general manager of enough
was the auditor from working in KPMG and
while the auditor
of BPA from
2008 until 2011.
and when finished in KPMG
she went to be the general manager of
enough for sure she was the auditor
from all the activity of BPA
Spanish Bank bank of Madrid has filed
for bankruptcy customers rushed to empty
their accounts bpas Banco Madrid
simultaneously goes bankrupt the Spanish
media members of the government
went to official of the TV saying that
Banco Madrid was a launderer machine and
crimes everywhere now there are
sentences
of the Court and state that there was no
laundering at all in Bank of Madrid but
the thing is done the order was to
liquidate it also on March 12th the
andoran government and enough seized
full control of BPA resulting in the
majority of bpa's management fired and
sent home until further notice I've been
going to be today I say
today is the end
he was he was fired but not not just
fire but he didn't well he was he wasn't
able to work as an economist Amura March
13 2015 72 hours after America's section
311 John Paul Miguel pratz bpa's CEO is
arrested and spends the next two years
in prison which is the maximum time
allowed to be held in prison under
andoran law without the enduring police
requiring any burden of proof that an
actual crime has been committed I never
imagined that could happen in two years
that's not normal what is there that is
allowing them to to arrest him what do
they have
and he ended up that they didn't have
anything March 16 2015 six days after
America's section 311 Jordi sinka
andorra's Minister of Finance goes on
National Television
ES
transparencia
torsion
the infamous Panama papers leak revealed
that Mr Geordie sinka before becoming
andorra's Finance Minister was also the
owner of an offshore company this
company was in the business of the blood
diamond trade Geordie singer held
significant shares in an enduring
company called orfund a conglomerate
dedicated to Golden diamonds three
subsidiaries of this group operated in
Liberia under the bloodthirsty dictator
Charles Taylor who gave tax privileges
to one of orfund subsidiaries Charles
Taylor is currently sentenced to 50
years in prison for crimes against
humanity at a special war crimes Court
in The Hague and it was proven in court
that the Civil War he waged that led to
the rape dismemberment and murder of
countless civilians was financed by the
diamond trade Jordy Cinco was not merely
a shareholder he also actively worked
with the orphund group sinka's name
appears on this document for example as
the sender of 500 000 pesetas to
the dictator's right-hand man involved
in that civil war with whom this
endoring company was working with to be
able to exploit the blood diamond mines
in Liberia in addition Jordi sinka had
contact through this company with
Fernando Fernandez rabbleda an associate
of one of the largest arms dealers in
Africa
is controllers
[Music]
concludes his National address without
mentioning that he contracted
pricewaterhousecoopers to begin auditing
bpa's alleged money laundering activity
how the government of Andorra manage
to know if in BPA there were a lot of
criminals Contracting prize Waterhouse
prize Waterhouse is an American
firm who is one of the big four and if
pricewaterhouse says it is good it is
good and it says it is bad it is bad and
the United States will accept it because
it's price I was there when
pricewaterhouse came to to BBA I was
there and I saw how they work so your
knowledge have they found anything wrong
no not at all not at all
and nothing but
but this is not possible
here it must be something wrong but it
feels that it says it is true finally
they had to make something unbelievable
they asked me
because I'd feel at first I I thought
they were in good faith and I wasn't
with faith they asked me okay
tell us which are the complicated
customers the customers if you have to
suspicious to make any suspicious of
your customers which will be that
customers and I make a list for them and
the list was the least that they say
that have the clients that has not
passed I'm nothing else in other words
after analyzing 15 million transactions
spanning seven years of more than 37 000
accounts pricewaterhousecoopers found
zero evidence of money laundering at BPA
pricewaterhousecoopers then asks Isabel
bpa's compliance officer to make a list
of possible suspicious accounts which
were immediately placed into the money
laundering pile which amounted to
2165 customers or 7.4 percent of bpa's
open accounts amounting to 32.4 percent
of the entire monetary value of deposits
of BPA
um what happens
Lions passed through a crucifixion well
president house Coopers came to Andorra
with a lot of young economies very young
and
make a
back work for me
there are nothing
worse than an incompetent with
initiative
in order for pricewaterhousecoopers to
keep their charade alive they needed to
invent reasons for these customers to be
categorized as money launderers they
accomplished this by demanding proof of
origin for each and every penny
deposited in these selected accounts
thus creating an instant demand for
andorra's legal professionals is
foreign
you asked me about when I buy a car
are you crazy
or this F 500 euros and what you do with
this I don't remember
ah you got a money launder if you don't
know they must demonstrate the origin of
the money is good you will not get it oh
but it belongs to my father and my
father is dead I don't know how to
how many accounts holders you
representes
700 to 1000 years
he is
so
um
the theater
is
foreign
foreign
of any wrongdoing no money laundering so
far
your Porto
the lord of the beginning
so pricewaterhousecooper's job is now
finished yes no uh there are they still
here four years later yes yes are they
still working on this today this price
Waterhouse yes
what are they doing today
well I'm asking for stupid things
justify that we are body Learners on
this process
everybody are guilty
until proved there are innocence is
on April 2nd 2015 23 days after
America's section 311 a new law is
passed in Andorra and Arab is formed
with the purpose of managing the
processes of resolution of banking
entities with its board of directors
appointed by the Minister of Finance
Jordy sinka and the enough directed by
Maria cassan
one of the chief architects of the new
andoran law that created Aaron was
Xavier espat andorra's Minister of
Justice at this time who today is now
the elected president of Andorra is
here
foreign
[Music]
very sport Iran actionistas
after then Minister of Justice Xavier
espat manipulated the Arab law his
family were allowed to keep all of their
cash deposits at BPA while the majority
shareholders and founders of BPA and
Banco Madrid Raymond and hajini sierko
locally known as the sierko brothers
watched all of their cash deposits
vanish as did many members of bpa's
General management not only were Xavier
espat's family the second largest
shareholders of BPA they are a very
wealthy family that own a chain of 70
luxury cosmetic stores across Spain and
Andorra Julia perfumery who were also
named in the Panama papers
era that begins plans to create a good
bank to place what
pricewaterhousecoopers has deemed as
legitimate assets segregated from BPA
with plans to immediately sell the new
bank once it's set up June 17 2015 three
months after America's section 311 Arab
creates Val Bank as its new good bank
where 67.6 of bpa's deposits are safely
placed with the remaining 32.4 percent
being placed into what is locally
referred to as the BPA tomb two days
later andorra's co-prince the prime
minister of France travels to Andorra
for the first time in history
followed in December by andorra's other
co-prints from Spain
[Music]
[Music]
for me
is
[Music]
also at this time the sierko brothers
begin engaging in a multi-year legal
battle with the United States Treasury
and fencing even addressing the director
of fincen herself Jennifer Calvary
our view was then and still my view now
that a great Injustice was done to these
folks BPA was
one of the good ones the moment that the
section 311 notice was issued that had
the intent and effect of all U.S banks
saying we will no longer clear your
dollars and when an International Bank
can no longer clear dollars
they're done they were in question they
weren't asked they weren't given a day
to explain themselves it just happened
and overnight they were shut down you
have a chance to respond but by the time
you respond uh you've been out of
business for a week two weeks three
weeks a month no U.S bank will deal with
you and you're finished and again you
say well how can you expropriate a bank
section 311 of the Patriot Act allows
them to do it we challenge that we said
there must be there must be some way to
say no no you've gotten it wrong here
let's get this sorted out but of course
it behooves the treasury to run out the
clock because the longer that a bank
stays without the ability to operate the
less chance there is
to reinstate it and it goes down to the
vanishing point very quickly later on
when the family owner of the bank
was going to a lawyers in the United
States trying to get Justice from this
operation Vincent
exceptionally
withdraw the measure and the accusation
against bibia February 19 2016 fincen
withdraws its finding under Section 311
regarding banka Bravada deandora as BPA
no longer operates in a manner that
poses a threat to the U.S financial
system
less than one year after issuing the
notice the fencing withdraws the notice
the notice that has been withdrawn
quicker in the whole history of things
establishing a record
this is very strange
the fact was that the petition to the
court was to get
the document or the information that
have conducted Vincent to take this
strong decision and the judge
said well if Vincent withdraw the
measure
there is no documents required if it is
withdraw there is no accusation no
guiltiness and you can go away yes but
we are dead you had in your hands a
knife
you killed me but then
you take the knife out of my body and
say well no no the knife is here if you
die that's up to you and it was a
strategic maneuver to essentially take
away
the notice that was the trigger that
gave us a right to respond
so it was a was a really arbitrary use
of power that was unreviewable to shut
down a bank without any meaningful
ability to go forward and so we ended up
with a U.S government coordinated with
another country made a victim of a
private bank shut it down made it unable
to come back to life sold the assets for
uh you know for a pittance to another a
U.S entity called JC flowers Chris you
have a history of buying cheap assets in
crisis times we do try to buy banks in
times of Crisis but we have mostly stuck
to the mature markets not the emerging
markets that has its own level of
colorful risk which might be too
colorful for us April 21st 2016 13
months after America's section 311
American private Equity Firm J.C flowers
purchases Val Bank good morning my name
is
foreign
specific
economic aspects of the the operation
set up around BPA and the beach Man
created to
resolve I mean the situation at the end
of the day summarizing
in one of the most convoluted confusing
yet clever displays of sheer economic
gymnastics a story that by itself
deserves its own feature documentary JC
flowers purchased the valbank a business
valued at 119 million euros from the
government of Andorra for only 16.6
million euros to simplify the details of
this transaction the sale price of
valbank was 29.8 million euros but JC
flowers paid 3.8 million euros the
convertible bonds or shares of common
stock in the bank were valued at 70
million euros but JC flowers paid 12.8
million euros meaning that JC flowers
acquired an existing profitable
international business at an astounding
86 discount
what means that well they make a baby
profit baby
when I say they add meditation flowers
have you ever seen anything like this in
your career no no 73 years old and I
have never seen
I even cannot imagine something like
this because
the owners the original owners of BBA
lost everything with this cell of the
bank to DC flowers and so you are
spending time and effort and money
to do an autopsy not to try and do a
cure for what's happened
America's actual section 311 notice
against BPA claimed that BPA had
facilitated transactions involving the
proceeds of organized crime corruption
human trafficking and fraud for the
Mexican Sinaloa drug cartel the country
of Venezuela Russian criminal
organizations and companies in China
the entire scope of America's allegation
that BPA was laundering money for the
Chinese related to a Chinese businessman
named GAO ping GAO ping immigrated from
China to Spain in the 1990s and rose
from a small time cook in a Chinese
restaurant to becoming a big time
multi-million Euro businessman and art
dealer he initially built his fortune by
importing Chinese leather products into
Spain and then reselling the products
for cash in 2012 more than two years
before America's section 311 galping and
dozens more were arrested in Spain in
one of the biggest tax evasion
operations in Spanish history
[Music]
has never come to Andorra and we have
never seen him
gal Ping's only relationship to andoran
banking was through one of his
high-ranking managers Rafael paidado who
was also arrested in 2012. in fact
Rafael peliardo had multiple bank
accounts linked to galping in Andorra
not just BPA
he travels frequently to China
factories to China
and things like that and said them in
Barcelona as bpa's head of compliance
Isabel requested proof that this
operation was a fully legitimate
business and we start working with cars
but not too much gas is
very very common in Andorra in that
moment galping was committing tax fraud
in Spain by depositing cash in andoran
Banks his operations started with Rafael
payardo driving with cash from Spain
into Andorra to deposit into his bank
accounts from there Bank wires from
hyardo's accounts would be sent to China
to pay for more products to be shipped
back to Spain to be sold
but in two years the cast makes me it
was something like the 2008 all the
businesses are
really really bad and you are like
while the world was dealing with the
aftermath of the 2008 banking crisis
Rafael paardo began expanding this
operation by granting large amounts of
cash from galping's business to anyone
in Spain who needed quick cash on hand
in exchange for an immediate bank wire
reimbursement between bank accounts in
Andorra the economy was in crisis so
what a lot of people did and said okay I
have this half a million euros offshore
I need that money right now just to pay
service and to pay stuff and since the
Spanish police knew this they were at
the border just controlling basically
every car and that's why they
appreciated so much this system we are
not so comfortable we are getting
something like 15 euros for the price
fit and we are assuming a lot of risk of
the gas we have both banko Madrid BPA
was aware they couldn't continue working
with Spanish customers who were
intentionally evading Spanish taxes
while BPA was simultaneously operating a
bank on Spanish soil and for this reason
is because we stopped the operation in
2011 2011.
Vincent note
March 2015.
incredible when the note appears when
you say this this is prehistoria this is
past very very fast to summarize BPA
opens an account for Raphael payardo in
2008. BPA fires him as a client and
closes his bank account in 2011. more
than one year later Raphael paardo is
arrested alongside gal ping for tax
fraud in 2012. three years before
America's section 311 but that's not the
interesting part shortly after BPA fired
Rafael paardo as a client in 2011 gal
ping asked him to set up a fake meeting
with one of galping's Partners Yong Jun
Yang luring two BPA employees into
Yang's office in Madrid pretending to
see about opening a new bank account at
BPA then trying to trick BPA employees
into admitting something galping could
use against them all while a hidden
camera was recording the entire meeting
oblivious to what was happening BPA
refused to open a bank account for Mr
yang galpeng tried to use this tape in a
failed extortion attempt against BPA by
threatening to go to the media with this
tape if BPA didn't take Rafael paardo
back as their client
is very afraid of the Chinese and they
record him and then Rafa came to Andorra
and asked the commercial okay we have a
record that say that so you are not
going to stop us
forget forget about it if we decide to
stop you we are going to stop you for us
it's not a problem going to where are
you going with this we didn't make any
any drama of it this video recorded in
2011 was discovered on a USB drive by
Spanish police during their massive
galping tax evasion arrests in 2012. the
video was publicized after 2015. March
17 2015 one week after America's section
311 an edited version of galping's
failed extortion video suddenly appears
on National Spanish media as proof that
BPA was laundering money for the Chinese
foreign
what's the message
remember when bpa's CEO John pal Miguel
pratz was arrested just 72 hours after
America's section 311 and held in prison
for two years without charges well the
reason for John Powell's arrest was
because Spanish police threw Rafael
paardo in the back of a Spanish police
car drove him across the border to
Andorra and forced Rafael to give false
testimony in front of an enduring judge
against John Paul Miguel pratts leading
to his arrests
[Music]
those only physical evidence against
John Powell Miguel Pratt was one of
Raphael's own handwritten cash for wire
transfer agendas with the partial name
Jean Powell Raphael later admits that
Spanish police forced him to falsify his
testimony yet John pal Miguel Pratt's
remains in Endor in custody for two
years anyway he continues to stand by
his story claiming I have been a puppet
of the prosecutor and the court who have
used me to justify the intervention of
the bank but in the same agenda figures
the name of some other person in some
other banks in Andorra which should be
also in jail in The Craze is the same
and are not
and never have been according to reports
from the andoran police department
scores of people were taking advantage
of Rafael paardo's cash for wire
transfer service ranging from famed
porno actor nacho Vidal to the family of
andorra's Minister of Justice Xavier
aspot and Dora's 2019 elected president
and head of government
thank you
and in our case
everybody is processed someone's in
prison and in the other case nothing
happened and the case does not advance
why not
in one hand the police is saying
the bank is hiding this
and on the other hand is saying thank
you very much Mr bank because if it
wasn't because of your records we
wouldn't been able to cross all these
transactions it was like Hey I mean
Andorra had five banks at this time ANS
Bank credit Andorra Mora Bank Banks
abadel de Andorra and BPA four of
endora's five banks were engaging in
identical operations for galping through
Raphael payardo but only BPA was
intervened
they did the same operation with gulping
exactly the same operations
exactly
they always work with Euro
never
they make any transfer or BPI the BPA
receive cash in US dollar
so this is this means American
authorities under American correspondent
Banks they couldn't know
the existence
of this operation
it means that the information from this
plugin
comes from Spain
America's section 311 alleging that BPA
was laundering money for the Russians
focuses on a man named Andre Petrov
exactly how Rafael payardo was GAO
Ping's Handler Mr Andre Petrov was a
Handler for a former decorated Russian
army General winner of the Science and
Technology State's prize for the Russian
Federation and acting CEO of a company
responsible for cleaning and repairing
all of Russia's oil pipelines Mr Victor
canenkin we know that this is a very
important person in Russia has a lot of
money so he he put some money here it's
not uncommon for a man as wealthy as
Victor canenkin a public figure living
and working in Russia to place their
money offshore in hopes of discouraging
a kidnapping or other potential security
risks so that was here like this that
was for me so clear that that client
wasn't nothing wrong Victor canancan's
activity consisted of two transfers from
a bank in Latvia to BPA one in 2003 for
20 million euros and another in 2007 for
30 million euros under the company name
DDC limited the money comes from his own
company I mean it's a transfer from one
pocket to another pocket chase the
country nothing else we are not sailing
we are not buying we are not making any
business I just have my money here and I
want to change this to another country
upon the 30 million euros deposit in
2007 BPA contacted the Latvian bank to
confirm the standing of Victor
Connecticut and DDC Limited
the following year BPA commissioned
Kroll a compliance risk and diligence
firm headquartered in New York City to
independently audit Victor Connecticut's
activity for anti-money laundering and
Corruption
opened an account here in in Andover and
and gets the money from the account of a
big talk to the count of petrol that's
all Mr salary for me like compliance not
significative January 2013 two years
before America's section 311 against BPA
Andre Petrov is arrested by Spanish
police for corruption and tax evasion
crimes that are completely unrelated to
Victor Connecticut however more than two
years later on March 23 2015 13 days
after America's section 311 against BPA
the Spanish media suddenly releases a
series of claims linking Victor
Connecticut to Andre petrov's criminal
activities Spanish media also claimed
that two Executives from BPA travel to
Moscow to visit Victor konenkin in
person with one of those Executives
being Santiago rosello which was true as
it was santi's job as Financial director
of BPA to closely Monitor and
periodically visit a client as big as
Victor canenkin the Spanish media also
reports that the other BPA executive on
this Moscow trip was Pablo La Plana
publishing that he had been arrested
nine months earlier by andoran police
for laundering drug money
is lying when they say that I want to
Russia the Spanish police is lying when
they say that I stayed at such a pill
this lying when they said that I pick up
my passport at the Barcelona Airport I
mean that all those are like two days
after this was published the law firm of
Eric Lewis wrote this Spanish newspaper
requesting the removal of these
defamatory claims as well as a
retraction proving he did not go to
Russia and was never implicated in drug
money laundering yet to this day ABC
Spain has refused to edit this article
even though they are completely aware
that this article is a humongous lie it
was coordinated Vincent issues to notice
against BPA and suddenly all these are
articles about BPA about myself about
everything just is there this was
planned while Spanish police were
arresting Andre patroff in January 2013
something else was being coordinated the
police called me hey hi I'm the police I
have an account that has to be locked
today it was a
Friday night I say okay I'm having
dinner with my with my husband at the at
the restaurant no no we have to lock it
now okay
the bank is closed it's not nothing is
going to happen to Monday no no you have
to go to the background you have to lock
it right now okay bring me the the
notice to the to the restaurant he came
to the restaurant
I was having dinner and I'll open the
envelope and it's here I signed and I
see
Victor kanikin the Russian oh my God
you remember that Customer because it
was a big customer and when the police
left I take the phone
and I called
Santi my phone when the Russian people
wear clothes in jail in January 2013 my
my phone was being plugged up
and all my conversations were recorded
during one month I didn't know and you
say hi Santi Samuel here
the police has come they have locked
Victor can I get
Andre petrol of both Santi says what but
that's not possible he's our businessman
we have everything
yes I'm sure that we have everything
perfect in that account we have nothing
to to worry because the account is
perfectly documented okay okay bye bye
when we know this we offer my
presentation to the audience
saying with us and understand what
happened with me
I can explain what you need I come to
the internet United to explain
whatever you like they say no don't
worry you you are not relevant in the
case and you are not a part of the case
this is in 2013 when in 2015 we have the
intervention of BBA Spain then decides
to resurrect this case Santi was
suddenly facing a year in jail and 300
000 Euros in fines if convicted
the police make the interpretation of
the conversation clearly both of them
know what's happening and they are
saying that everything is perfect
because they know that we were recording
them and they want to hide that there is
something wrong that was the police
interpretation
of my conversation
with Sandy santi's case finally made it
to court in October 2018 only to be
immediately acquitted because there was
no case it was not appealed by the
persecutor so its film is a solution I
know that a Petrov has also an account
in in a bank according to andoran police
reports showing records dating as far
back as 2007 Andre Petrov was also using
ansbank for his activities with more
than three quarters of a million euros
in deposits yet no action has ever been
taken against onbank or its employees
Finn sends section 311 against BPA also
claims that Andre petroff is suspected
to have links to Simeon mogalevich one
of the FBI's most wanted fugitives this
may be the most powerful man you've
never heard of his name is Simeon
mogalevich the Russian mobster he has
access to so much including funding
including other criminal organizations
that he can with a telephone call affect
the global economy yet no state agency
has produced a shred of evidence to
support a link between the two men one
day Santa comes to me and says hey send
coordinate a meeting between the new
manager of the international business
unit and Mr Petrov I need to send an SMS
to Petrov I have never seen him before I
have never interacted with him before
and because of that SMS the Spanish
Police Stopped my phone while Santi was
a lead manager for bpa's Russian clients
involved in America's section 311 Pablo
was a lead manager for bpa's Venezuelan
clients involved in America's section
311.
America's fincen alleges that a money
laundering Network engaged in a wide
variety of business for illicits profit
connected to Venezuelan government
officials including Venezuela's public
Oil Company padavevesa the owner of
Cisco at the time
never sent money to BBA and this is
something that blows my mind when they
when I read their notice of fun because
you won't find any single transaction
sent from
while manufacturing the story that BPA
was laundering money for the Venezuelans
the Spanish police had to get really
creative during this National Spanish
news broadcast that aired on April 7
2015 a month after America's section
311. the audience was told that the
Spanish police had been tapping the
phones of BPA Executives while trying to
follow the Russian mafia but suddenly
the Venezuelans just happened to appear
on the scene so Spanish police started
tapping the phones related to bpa's
Venezuelan clients even though Spain's
police were tapping phones inside
Andorra the Spanish police had no
jurisdiction to intervene in a case
between Venezuela and Andorra and this
is where America's fincen came in
Spanish police then presented to
America's fincen evidence of money
laundering at BPA for all the clients
mentioned in America's section 311
including Venezuela thus resulting in
America shutting down BPA and Banco
Madrid the first
time I saw a conversation of mine was on
a newspaper a rib and the transcription
was so wrong
but the next wave was that shocked me
was when I started to hear and then to
see in the in the television to hear my
conversations during this same April 7
2015 broadcast Spanish media started
playing Pablo laplanas re-edited phone
conversations on National Television as
proof that BPA was laundering money for
the Venezuelans Pablo leplana had no
idea his phone was being recorded in
2013 until he watched and heard his own
re-edited phone conversations broadcast
live on National Spanish TV in April
2015. two years later perfectly
coinciding with America's section 311
against BPA it's very frustrating when
they are lying and you said I can prove
that that's not true
and but you can't Pablo immediately
hired an attorney and took this case to
court in May of 2015 just weeks after
the first broadcast his attorney
presented diagrams to the court showing
how his conversations had been highly
manipulated when aired but no
retractions were ordered and the Spanish
justice system did nothing to remedy the
situation when when I when you're
watching when you're hearing your
conversations and you see that those
have been edited I Can't Describe I
can't find the words to describe the the
level of frustration and anger that that
generates with Venezuela there are two
types of business one with the insurance
company bpa's Venezuelan clients
consisted partly of International
Insurance brokers who shopped for
reinsurers like guy Carpenter or Lloyd's
of London to ensure various National
businesses in Venezuela and the other
with the China companies these clients
also broker deals to build factories in
Venezuela using Chinese technology as
well as importing wholesale vehicles
from China for retail in Venezuela
we create the money in Andorra from the
company with the taxes with the delusion
with all the everything publicly
released andoran court documents
redacted the names of the numerous
Venezuelan clients of BPA but they did
list the other Banks they were working
with with these Banks depositing 90
percent of the Venezuelans Capital into
BPA with this list of banks that the
Venezuelans had wired most of its money
to yet no Bank in this list was ever
investigated or had a section 311 placed
against them
foreign
of the unit of financial investigation
in Andorra they considered its activity
suspicious when we were asked for these
clients to get 50 million dollars away
from the bank
we advised and they immediately said no
no no block the money and then the
person in church put it in a court and
accused these people of money laundering
in November 2012 more than two years
before America's section 311 the
blocking of Venezuelan assets at BPA for
this alleged money laundering went to
trial in Andorra the Court's final
decision was to lift and void this
imposed block finding no wrongdoing
the general attorney
was not confident with this decision and
asked to investigate it again this case
was then escalated to a higher enduring
Court dated July of 2014 eight months
before America's section 311 still
without having provided sufficient
evidence of crime or money laundering
it was finally delivered but not all
they still left some money in the bank
they were innocent
Joseph and Tony Silvestri was one of the
local andoran attorneys representing the
Venezuelans in this case the judge under
and the tribunal the highest tribunal
says there are no proof that Venezuela
and make laundry money
and I'm freeze all the accounts after
this me and all the lawyer received the
the payment of or Services after that
came the
the fins and notice and talk about the
Venezuelan citizens and freeze again the
accounts with all the process anti-money
laundering of
BBA look my account
account of the other lawyer and say hey
what's this amount
this amount came from the Venezuelan the
judge umphreys
and say ah okay you're a laundry you you
make laundry money are you crazy is the
judge who unfriends he's a judge who say
there are no proof in Andorra
to be a lawyer is a risky profession
this is human rights attorney and
partner of the European Center for
constitutional and human rights Gonzalo
Boyer who has been representing Joseph
and Tony in this case
judge who released the money
before defensive note is the same judge
is the same person the same human being
that is charging Sylvester and the
others lawyer for money laundering out
of the money that she has declared is
clean money
so at the end of the day you don't know
what to do
I mean you win a case
out of that case you're paid and you end
up in a worse situation that declined
that you acquitted after that start a
case against me and against my wife
because she's co-owner of the account
I think this is a
process to make fear to the to the
lawyers
on my money in BBA all my money of all
my career was fixed everything
that lost everything I start from zero
um I'm upset together they are currently
seeking the attention of the United
Nations demonstrating massive human
rights violations within the country of
Andorra if you don't know how to manage
a case you indict the lawyer
that's the problem
and finally the fourth case in America's
section 311 alleges that BPA worked with
the Sinaloa drug cartel in Mexico and
facilitated the transfer of bulk cash
derived from narcotics trafficking in
the United States this would mean that
the Sinaloa drug cartel after being cut
off from HSBC in the United States for
doing this exact same thing with no
section 311 being ordered against HSBC
would now manage to somehow transport
huge amounts of cash by boat or plane
from the United States to Andorra to
then deposit into BPA it's possible that
Vincent needs
too stupid to put this case in the in
the note
I never found a single indicator
whatever nor has anyone pointed to one
that had anything to do with the Sinaloa
cartel or anybody else and there's
nothing that even sniffs at that that's
that's what we found uh and now when we
have been in the US through all the
different courts and we arrived to the
end and one of the judges asked the
prosecutor representing Vincent said
well have you shown any proofs and all
she can respond is that we have issued a
statement about this and the judge he
asks at her again this is an English
process at any instances from the
beginning have you shown any proofs of
the charges that you have against BPA
that has Justified the intervention of
the bank says well when we have done
this issue and he gets upset he said
listen have you or have you not
shown any proves and she has nothing to
say because he's upset already at this
point he said no your honor that's where
we are I mean they're building
everything based on the criminal
credibility of Vincent not on evidence
because if they could have can evidence
this case will be in the U.S in a U.S
court and not in an enduring Court I
mean the whole endurance judicial system
you can put it into one courtroom in New
York why did you choose this to do it
because you don't have a case
it was the time of the us being very
careful and watchful of what was going
on in Venezuela you know being with the
Russians so they would like the spices
to make it all tasteful and appealing to
the US government let's go for this plus
this is a small country no certificates
whatsoever a small bank so no one is
really going to complain about this we
have a political and strategic interest
in getting along with the Spanish
they may not fully believe the Spanish
myself just go out with them go with the
floor let's make them happy and so
you've got two countries coordinating
but they're basically coordinating to
deprive
in you know innocent folks from being
able to have a meaningful remedy it's
troubling it should be troubling to
everybody and it can it could happen to
anyone anywhere and the banks are not
going to fight and the foreign
Regulators aren't going to fight they
didn't fight for their bank they they
decided that they would circle the
wagons around the other Banks and do the
US's bidding the penalty would be borne
by
the catalons
in their midst
the penalty would be born by
catalans it
by now you are likely asking yourself
why
what would be the motivation for Andorra
and Spain to justify framing BPA for
money laundering intentionally
destroying the bank and countless lives
in the process
it's got a name loafer
that's the reality
everything that's behind this issue is a
law firm it's a war with other means
which is uh using
legal tools within the legal system
to destroy the enemies
in a way that appears to be legal
so they explored the the contradictions
of the law and they use the legal system
why because normally
in each country the the use the the
judicial system doesn't go the contract
power a counterpower or or checks and
balance and would have happened in
Honduras exactly the same they wanted to
protect the bank
who was convenient for them and they
want to destroy another why this other
bank BPA was not convenient because they
didn't want to play along in certain
things that were important both
friendora and also for Spain which was a
campaign to destroy
the Catalan movement
for for me was not a surprise because we
know perfectly how the Spanish state
Acts or or reacts when the Spain feels
threatened by someone
is a former Empire
as a former Empire made by violence and
genocides
he has no limits
and he has a sense of the power linked
to the concept of impunity
it doesn't matter if Andorra is an
independent and sovereign state the
Spanish police could act inside the
Spanish state in australandora so for us
was not
a surprise to discover the dark side of
the Spanish state is acting against
Catalan interest
Spain consists of 17 regions the most
famous being Madrid Spain's ruling
capital and Catalonia where Barcelona is
located
these two regions have been in bitter
Conflict for centuries
in the 18th century Spain has tried to
eliminate
introduce Spanish during the administer
through the administration the public
administration and through the roles and
through the school because at this time
during two centuries it was really
Katana was forbidden in the schools we
remain at the time for instance the
papers in catarawa Forbidden and the
broadcasting Academy was forbidden and
the television at the time of framework
the Spanish language was first imposed
on the Catalan people nearly 300 years
ago even though most spoke only Catalan
successive Spanish governments launched
decree after decree to weaken the use of
the Catalan language in 1881 it was
banned on legal documents in 1896 in
public meetings and on the telephone in
1900 in the theater in 1939 when
Francisco Franco came to power it was
banned absolutely everywhere people
caught speaking in Salon were arrested
and severely beaten
or even reading a book in Catalan in
public places was considered a direct
protest against Franco's long-running
fascist regime a regime that has left
Spain second only to Cambodia for the
highest number of missing persons
you had a fascist dictator of Franco in
this Bank who had this fascist dictator
Hitler in Germany when that resolved
there was trials there was a conclusion
to that and there was no conclusion that
anything you want to say in that regard
yeah so
um
was it fake the Spanish transition to
democracy was a fake
because first Franco has that in a bet
as a head of a state
no Revolution no pressures against
fascismus has removed
Franco from Power
but biology
since the death of Francisco Franco in
1975 the ghost of his fascist ideals
remained prominent in Spain to this day
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
with the continued repression of
Catalonia taking Center Stage
[Music]
ever since I was a little girl I've been
seeing these differences I would go to
the supermarket and I would found an
elder woman speaking in Spanish with her
grandchild telling them in Spanish don't
buy this this is Catalan and I would
think you are living in Catalonia how
can you say that how can you be opposing
a product that's made in this land this
has nothing to do with politics I have
traveled a lot in Spain since I was a
little kid and I would find people
insulting me and my sister for speaking
in Catalan with each other they would
come to us and say you're in Spain you
should speak Spanish like very
ugly situations and very uncomfortable
situations and I've been encountering
this my entire life
[Music]
the first catalonian statute of autonomy
was passed by the Spanish parliament in
1932 after Catalonia held a public Vote
or referendum with 99 of catalonians
voting in favor of this statute but
seven years later once Francisco Franco
took power this statute was abolished
resulting in four Decades of repression
and bloodshed against the catalonian
people after Franco died in 1975 another
statute of autonomy was drafted and
passed in 1979 but it granted Catalonia
only limited autonomy from 1980 to 2003
president Jordi pujol dedicated his
presidency to Catalonia's right to
self-governance and gave birth to what
is known today as the catalonian
independence movement
stepped down in 2003 and new government
in Catalonia appear the main goal of
that new government was to develop a new
statute of autonomy for the country I
was the head of the opposition at that
time in the Catalan Parliament I was
fully involved in this political
operation and then I personally
negotiated with president sapatero at
that time the Spanish prime minister I
negotiated with him the statute of
autonomy and we reached an agreement and
that agreement was transformed in a
Spanish law
proved in the Spanish Parliament by an
absolute majority then that law was sent
to Catalonia and in Catalonia there was
a binding referendum and the outcome of
the referendum was 74 percent of the yes
vote so the statute of autonomy the new
statutes of the atomy was okay and four
years after that in 2010 the Spanish
constitutional Court struck down the
main articles of the new statute of
autonomy in Catalonia that had been
previously approved in a binding
referendum by people
one of the members of the judges of the
three constitutional Tribune which is
the top the one that said doesn't matter
what the people has decided doesn't
matter what the Departments this cannot
happen came to New York
because he and his wife were very close
friends to one of my in-laws at home we
had breakfast at home
I said why all this you know why don't
we try and he told me Miguel you were
the catalans make money
but don't forget Spain is run from
Madrid
in 2012 2013 they were in Catalonia and
in Barcelona specifically huge
demonstrations more than 1.5 million
people in the streets asking for a
referendum and this is what I tried to
negotiate with President Hoya at that
time Spanish prime minister
and the answer of President Ahoy was
always the same there is nothing to talk
about my position was if you look at
what is really happening in Catalonia
and you see in a Consolidated democracy
that more than 1.5 million people are in
the streets asking for a referendum your
answer is there is nothing to talk about
in November 2014 President Arthur Moss
decided to hold a non-binding symbolic
referendum not an actual referendum the
equivalent of taking an opinion poll of
the catalonian population for
self-autonomy 80 percent of voter
turnout voted in favor of Independence
back in Madrid president Mariano rajoy's
government responded by convicting
president Archer Moss of Civil
Disobedience banned him from holding
public office for two years and find his
party nearly 5 million euros mayor of
Girona carlis puccimon has been voted in
as the new president of Catalonia the
move puts the northeastern region back
on the road to secession from Spain
after months of political deadlock and
waning support in his predecessor
autumnas
we are a minoring a national minority in
Spain we are only 16 of the Spanish
population so we have no power enough to
be uh respected our decision because we
are a minority
so the only tool in the international
laws that protect minorities is the
right of self-determination
and the only way to achieve that is to
be independent in October 2017 president
carlis push demon authorized a binding
referendum for Catalonia's Independence
there are a lot of people in who doesn't
want independence but they want to vote
and then want to decide together with
the others they filter
and when I saw that day
and then I see also my my regards the
day there is only a word hope
obviously there was another word
violence
police are breaking their way into a
building so it looks very clear at this
very early stage in the voting process
that Madrid is not going to let this
happen
[Applause]
[Applause]
well here you can see protesters in
Sharona in northeastern Catalonia facing
off against officers will demonstrators
have their hands up in a sign of
non-violence but police apparently
started hitting them with batons
well another video from Catalonia shows
police jumping on and violently kicking
protesters as well as dragging the
activists out of a polling station
tossing peaceful voters downstairs
striking them with batons and
confiscating ballot boxes
catalans lined up to vote many paying a
high price for it now people are still
trying to vote here but we do know that
it's just two blocks away uh there was
there was another polling station
another building of the school that was
just basically raided by police forces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
out here
[Applause]
[Music]
but that was very disappointing for me
to discover Spain has not changed I was
very sad seeing
uh the hate in the face of Spanish
policemen
they were activists
in the name of the unity of Spain
they were not worried about the image of
Spain
that that image Spain offers to the
world
as authoritarian State violent state
it doesn't matter all that
was also a day of Shame for Spain
they shame for Europe I conducted my
interview with President Puja de mon in
September 2019 in Belgium where he
remains in Exile but just four weeks
after my interview this happened nine
catalog leaders will spend between 9 and
13 years behind bars for their roles in
staging an independence referendum back
in 2017 the vast majority of Voters said
they were in favor of breaking from
Spain and the regional Parliament
declared Catalonia's Independence but
Weeks Later Spain nullified the
independence declaration dissolved
Catalonia's Parliament and took Direct
Control of the region Spain's Supreme
Court handed down the sentences Monday
after finding the former leaders guilty
of sedition
thus triggering the worst political
crisis in Spain since the era of Franco
angry catalonians managed to shut down
Barcelona's airport and highway system
Madrid's repression of Catalonia isn't
just about culture it's also about money
according to a January 2020 treasury
report in 2015 and 2016 alone Catalonia
contributed to Spain 33.6 billion euros
more than it received
so what does Madrid's war with Catalonia
have to do with assassinating a private
bank in Andorra wait until you get a
load of this
in May of 2014 10 months before
America's section 311 against BPA
bpa's CEO John Powell Miguel pratz is
visited by the attache to the Spanish
Embassy in Andorra celestino barroso
John pal Miguel highly suspicious of
this meeting decided to record this
conversation with his phone
the mothers
saying money
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the castle
foreign
for this mystery meeting the person
meeting him was the head of internal
affairs of the national Spanish police
Martin Blass this is sworn courtroom
testimony of what happened in this
meeting
primary foreign
[Music]
the La Familia
um
the investigation led by the Spanish
government in Andorra trying to find a
personal accounts of President Peugeot
my accounts and vice president toriel
junkeras in my case well they failed
because there were no accounts in
Andorra although they thought that they
were there but they weren't
he said that we do not have them as a
client except for Joe but he could not
give any information because this was
not legal that he could not well then if
you do not do
accept the consequences
this is a coordinated work
between
Spanish police
and the treasury Department at least
at least I mean just
no doubt about that
because one
Heist rank officer of the warrior civil
in Spain
yes
when into TV is saying this is
so
they they even themselves they admitting
what they did
also this man Jose Manuel villarejo the
former commissioner for the Spanish
police was also hired to help frame BPA
is a very
Spanish character
I mean he has been very high
and now sit in a Cell in a prison but
Diego is a key person alongside with
other policemen in what was called
Catalina operation Operation Catalonia
which is very much related with the
blockage and the destroying of BPA but
when I'm saying very high he was working
for the government
he was a police officer but also a
private entrepreneur he intermediated in
a lot of
complicated situations and when I say
complicated situation people that were
journalists kidnapped in Syria by
terrorist groups and things like that
but he was making money out of
everything while he was a civil servant
and he has admitted several things one
of those is that he lied in order to
destroy BPA
where are the consequence until now we
haven't seen it I mean he got such an
amount of information that he talks
properly seriously clearly with all the
evidence on the table
and explain some people will have big
big troubles
even though the ruling government of
Andorra is comprehensively aware that
BPA was framed by Spain and tricked the
U.S treasury by presenting fake evidence
thus fully aware of the Innocence of the
managers of BPA and Dora's prosecutors
are still trying to imprison bpa's top
managers for money laundering this fake
criminal case continues into 2020 five
years after America's section 311. this
is something unbelievable the first
thinking is that you cannot believe it
when you wake up every morning you say
well I it must be something wrong I I I
have not wake up I must still be
dreaming because this is not real
but when you finally see that it is real
then comes a situation in which a
depression
faces in because you cannot accept that
and it threads all your parts of your
life
your family
and as I feel a lot of companions which
are in the same position
a lot of them for which I put my hand on
fire
and
it's impossible that the things that we
are being accused of
are truth I have a lot of angry in
myself I know that is not good and is
not healthy but I really do I cannot
avoid that I came to Andorra to work at
PPA in fact so I have been living here
for more than 20 years I'm Andorra now
first I was Spanish
and I I feel really really bad I get the
passport then the wrong passport because
my children are adorable my husband is
Andorra and I want to be all in the in
the same country
but if it's not for that I I would
I will not get the the andoran passport
because I feel really betrayed really
betrayed I feel really betrayed from the
supervisor from the Justice from
everywhere because I have been in a lot
of meetings with the supervisor telling
that we are doing things right
that we are working good with the
colleagues of other Banks saying that
okay Isabel please explain me how you do
this okay oh that's a good idea let's
make this let's talk about this
and at least they say that we are money
lenders we were working together because
we were very interested in in avoid
money laundering with the police I have
called the police a lot of times and we
have always helping them
because we thought that we are on the on
the right side
I mean their reputational damage has
been so big
that
I'm an employer as I said I mean no
company will hire me
at all because their reputation risk is
very high for that company and if even
if you want to start a business you will
find yourself that
you will need to get a bank account for
that business and it will be very hard
to do that I have still block all the
money in an mbpa you have no access to
that money no but not only this
I went to all the banks from Andorra
to open an account
and no Bank opened me an account
you know I leave from my wife
how much money is missing Olivia do we
know how much
from from the customers of VBA from the
the owners
in everything all maybe 1 billion one
more than one billion
wait would you say this was like a
clever bank robbery would you call it
that I have this feeling
what do you think would happen if
someone decided to allow everyone who
had money in BBA to have their money
back
what do you think would happen there's
not enough money
I told him at all there is not enough
money if someone the Justice would last
to to redo everything and everybody get
the money back from BPA is not possible
because there will not be enough money
to to get back to the customers
which is precisely why the enduring
justice system needs a guilty verdict
Andorra has even gone so far as to
publish the names of everyone from BPA
facing prison on the front page of its
largest newspaper advertising how long
they will spend in prison and how much
they will be paying in fines when found
guilty Jean-Paul eight years in prison
100 million euros in fines Santiago
eight years in prison 70 million euros
in fines Isabel seven years in prison 70
million euros in fines Joanne six years
in prison 70 million euros Pablo six
years in prison 70 million euros who are
guilty before trial
and because you are guilty before trial
um in in front of the public opinion the
state has the permission as allowed to
do all that state things necessary
to stop you
to prevent your succeed success
not only low fare but also media affair
s
foreign
to make matters more absurd while
Andorra is busy trying to place its own
innocent citizens in prison the andoran
government is simultaneously filing
lawsuits against Spain for extorting and
framing BPA for money laundering
yes
I could not get a single member of the
andoran government to speak to me on
camera about this story with the
exception of the head of the andoran
institute for human rights
Dinesh
a blank
uh
customer
you start with the Vincent note which is
a little butterfly
and on the other side of the world you
have a hurricane
some months later and this is what have
happened a little letter
with no support very small
move itself a bit and on the other side
of their planting was a proper hurricane
that devastate a bank families lawyers
and a lot of people I mean here is not
just a matter of money I mean when
people are indicted
they are under scrutiny they have a
social problem don't forget the door is
a very little country they were highly
respect people and now they are treated
like criminals
but not only the the owners and the
managers of BBA but also
something very important the lawyers and
why the lawyers are important because we
are the last line of defense
for many people
and if you are criminalized everybody
could be criminalized and at the end of
the day you see families destroyed
credibility is destroyed and a huge cost
in defense and people who don't know
where they will be in a year's time
cases already five years going on and
they don't know when it's going to come
to an end which will be the result
because let me it's very simple if you
shoot somebody you know more the less
which will be the result
but
if you haven't chewed anybody
and you're in a process for shooting
somebody you didn't should
the result could be anything so the
uncertainty is tremendous and the impact
on their lives and in their feelings and
their families and their kids because
all of them got kids is tremendous and
this is part of the devastation
of a hurricane created
with a small butterfly on the other side
of the Atlantic
do you think this will ever be resolved
this may be a case if anything you want
to say to stuff well I I I think really
you cannot resolve the effects
of the hurricane without resolving
what has caused it and that is not here
it's not in Andorra is in the U.S
thank you
remember Jennifer Calvary the director
of fincen she not only authorized the
section 311 against BPA but she is also
the one who negotiated hsbc's 1.9
billion dollar fine for laundering money
for the Sinaloa drug cartel guess where
she is today Jennifer Calvary who is
global head for financial crime threat
mitigation at HSBC
remember Jordy sinka the blood diamond
Smuggler who later became andorra's
Finance Minister and how he commissioned
America's pricewaterhousecoopers to
perform the BPA customers audit six days
after America's section 311. in
September 2019 Mr sinka was to be tapped
as the new director of an andoran branch
of pricewaterhousecoopers but his
position was aborted due to a serious
reputational problem however in January
2020 Jordi Cinco was appointed head of
andorra's retirement Reserve fund
endorse Social Security Administration
responsible for securing the andoran
citizens their retirement money
foreign
's cabinet still sits in a Spanish
prison in January 2020 the European
Union headquartered in Belgium has
granted president carlis puji Damon a
seat at the European Union Carlos Putnam
began his Mondays as MEP in Strasbourg
amid great media expectation before
attending the plenary session he called
on Europe for action and said Catalonia
is no longer an internal Spanish affair
so we are here in order to remember and
to claim to to European Union
institutions to be involved in a
solution based on dialogue
Mr Gonzalo Boyer is also president push
Demon's attorney I interviewed Mr Boyer
in August of 2019 when he proclaimed
this statement sooner than later they
will try to invite us for whatever money
laundering or whatever they will invent
it and they will try it because at the
end it's not a matter of result it's a
matter of destroying the person and
eight weeks later this happened
[Music]
foreign
with money in the andoran banking system
should consider three problems the first
is that it has a fractional Reserve
banking system but no Central Bank
there's therefore no one to act as
lender of Last Resort the second problem
is that Andorra uses the Euro as a
currency but is not in fact a member of
either the European Union nor the
Eurozone it therefore has no access to
the European Central Bank and more
importantly it has no method of printing
Euros in order to provide the banks with
liquidity and finally it has a third
problem Deposit Insurance and Dora has
this up to one hundred thousand Euros
per account but that lack of a central
bank and that lack of a way to print
Euros means that their insurance isn't
really all that much good
andorra's annual budget is only 470
million euros while andorra's Banks
collectively manage more than 49 billion
euros which is more than 100 times that
of andorra's annual budget and Dora's
annual budget doesn't cover half of what
is supposedly Frozen in BPA
sorry it's okay
hahaha
look you have to
to have this money from Andorra because
I believe that they are going to
disappear yes
[Music]